[Musique]
la politique maintenant et on peut
vraiment dire que c'est la confusion
chez les verts pour ne pas dire la
pagaille vous le savez après cette
remise en retrait pendant quelques jours
eva joly est revenu sur la scène
médiatique pour commenter l'accord signé
entre europe ecologie les verts et le
parti socialiste
le problème c'est que cette dernière
déclaration ne plaisent pas y compris à
ses plus proches son porte parole a
démissionné le ps demande aujourd'hui
des explications reportage ses fans
despinoy affaires dit ibrahim hadj et
pardon pour les petits problèmes de sons
que vous allez découvrir
yannick jadot pressé de questions
c'était samedi dernier à paris tenté le
grand écart avocats de l'accord
électoral avec le ps et en même temps
porte parole d'une eva joly très
critique vis-à-vis du texte aujourd'hui
le divorce est consommé il démissionne
car il se dit en désaccord avec la ligne
politique d'eva joly
après un silence de quelques jours eva
joly est en effet passé à l' attaque en
ciblant le parti socialiste vous en
voulez à françois hollande j'en veux aux
socialistes tav a cédé aussi visiblement
aussi directement au lobby du nucléaire
donc on ne pouvait pas dire oui je hais
route a plaidé françois hollande si je
ne me trompe pas d'ennemis mon objectif
est de battre nicolas sarkozy parce
qu'ils marchent pas vous répondre il ne
supporterait pas un deuxième mandat de
nicolas sarkozy
et qui oppose les français les uns aux
autres pouvez-vous récemment et mais
lyon c'est mon ennemi pouvez-vous
répondre à la question si les contours
pourquoi les principes si françois
hollande appellera à voter pour moi que
l'accord avec le ps ne la fasse pas
rêver soit mais les ténors d'europe
écologie du reproche de se tromper de
cible eva joly fait les mauvais choix
politiques qu'elle veuille marquer la
différence entre les écologistes et le
parti socialiste est normal mais il faut
faire la différence entre être
concurrents et adversaires et surtout
eva joly ne doit pas faire du saut ou du
super mélenchon s'il reste sur cette
position
flou et bien le fera campagne sans moi
ultime rebondissement tout à l'heure
face au tollé provoqué chez ses amis et
au ps eva joly corrige le tir elle fait
savoir qu'elle appellera bien à voter
hollande
[Musique]